[Music]
hey guys
welcome to another installment of Harry
Potter theory in this video we're going
to be dressing the question how many
witches and wizards are there not just
how many attend Hogwarts and not just
how many are there in the UK I'm talking
about how many are there total as of
April 2020 the current world population
is a staggering seven point eight
billion this means that if the Wizarding
community took up 1/10 of 1% of the
population
we'd still be left with seven hundred
and eighty thousand witches and wizards
across the globe the Harry Potter series
only exposes us to such a small
percentage of the Wizarding World
primarily focusing in on one Wizarding
school in one particular area of one
country granted Hogwarts is the only
Wizarding school in the UK but you get
my point if you're anything like me then
at some point is probably caused you to
ask yourself the question how many
witches and wizards are there we know
for certain that magical people don't
only exist in the UK and that magical
folk are taught at a variety of
wizarding schools across the globe
we've got Hogwarts in Scotland Bo Burton
in France Castle Oh Bruce Shu in Brazil
durmstrang in Northern Europe ilver
Morni in eastern North America MA who
took horror in Japan jugar do in Uganda
called doctorates in Russia and more the
list goes on in order to begin
formulating a reasonable answer to this
let's take a look at the number of
students that attend Hogwarts in an
interview in October 2001 who was asked
how many students attend Hogwarts and
how many students are there in each
house
Rowling replied with a very to-the-point
there are about a thousand students at
Hogwarts while it would be nice to just
take Rowling's word for it she has a
history of saying things and interviews
that heavily conflict with the world
she has introduced us to if there are
1000 students at Hogwarts then that
would mean that there are
250 students in each house students
attend Hogwarts for 7 years which means
that there would be approximately 36
students from each house per year if
there are an equal number of boys and
girls that would mean a hundred and
forty-four students
72 boys and 72 girls
that start at Hogwarts each and every
year this really doesn't add up with
what is depicted in the books or
portrayed in the films a more widely
recognized figure or at least a more
widely fan appreciated figure is 280
students of the school total that's 70
students from each house and 10 new
students per house per year this seems
to be far more consistent with the world
that we've been introduced to so I'm
going to roll with that figure moving
forward ok so that means that we have 40
new students that started Hogwarts each
year and this figure represents the new
magical students from the UK alone now
the population of the UK in 2020 is
approximately 68 million this means that
new Hogwarts attendees account for
approximately 0.00005
8 percent of the total UK population and
all 280 of the Hogwarts attendees
account for 0.0004 one percent is a
total UK population to put things into
perspective there are approximately 10
million students that attend regular
schools all ages in the UK this figure
represents 14 point 7 percent of the
total UK population 280 is zero point
zero zero to eight percent of 10 million
this means that for every one halt
student there are 35 thousand seven
hundred and fourteen regular students
which gives us a ballpark figure of one
magical pupil for every thirty-five
thousand seven hundred and fourteen
muggle pupils using this statistic we
can begin to form at least an estimate
for a figure revealing the total number
of magical folk in the UK
this is of course assuming that
Wizarding folk procreate about the same
amount of smuggles since we know the
number of full-time muggle students in
the UK accounts for fourteen point seven
percent of the entire UK population we
can rather safely apply the same figure
to total number of Hogwarts students two
hundred and eighty divided by zero point
one four seven or fourteen point seven
percent equals one thousand nine hundred
and four this means that if the number
of magical students attending Hogwarts
has any sort of relationship to the
number of muggle students attending
muggle school then we can safely assume
the UK has a Wizarding population
approximately one thousand nine hundred
and four
this would include parents teachers
Ministry of Magic staff and everyone
else but that's for the UK alone in an
interview Rowling has stated that she
imagines the Wizarding population of the
UK to be around three thousand but given
her history and the answer that she
provided regarding the number of
students at Hogwarts I'm not sure that
we can trust that I feel much more
comfortable with my own figure of 1904
from which we can derive zero point zero
zero to eight percent which represents
the total number of magical folk as a
proportion of the country's total
population so that's the UK sorted next
we need to look at the other countries
where wizarding schools exist as
populations vary from country to country
it wouldn't make much sense to assume
that whistling schools in other
countries accommodate the same number of
students as Hogwarts we need to look at
school attendees as a percentage of
total population from this we can derive
the total number of magical folk that
reside in these countries though there
are 11 visiting schools in total these
are the only ones that we know about UK
obviously France Brazil Uganda America
Japan Northern Europe and Russia let's
start with bow Bhutan in France
the population of France is actually
very similar to the UK at around 65
million and assuming that the percentage
of magical folk in France is comparable
to the UK it would give us a figure of
1820 medical folk and a student
population of 267 next let's move on to
Brazil which has a population of 212
million using the same formula this
would give us a total magical population
of 5,000 936 and a student population of
827 Uganda has a population of 40 5.7
million which leaves us with a total
magical population of 1279 and the
student population of 188 the u.s. has a
population of 330 million which leaves
us with a total magical population of
nine thousand two hundred and forty and
a student population of 1358 Japan has a
population of 126 million which gives us
a total magical population of 3528 and a
student population of 518 northern
Europe has a population of a hundred and
six million which gives us a total
magical population of two thousand nine
hundred and sixty eight in a student
population of 436 and lastly Russia has
a population of one hundred and forty
four point five million which gives us a
total magical population of 4046
and a student population of five hundred
and ninety-four there are also three
other wizarding schools eleven in total
but we don't have any information on
them the median figure for Wizarding
population among the eight countries
that we know is two thousand four
hundred and thirty six which multiplied
by three is seven thousand three hundred
and eight seven thousand three hundred
and eight plus twenty two thousand eight
hundred and thirty nine from all of the
other countries in the world
equals thirty thousand one hundred and
forty seven people that's thirty
thousand one hundred and forty seven
magical people living in the eleven
countries that have Wizarding specific
schools now we just have to figure out
the rest of the world now I think that
we can safely assume the places where
magical school to reside have denser
magical populations as the demand for
magical school would be higher but just
because other countries don't have a
magical school it doesn't mean that they
don't have a Wizarding population for
this reason I'm going to somewhat
arbitrarily assume that these countries
have a magical population that is half
as dense as the countries with magical
schools this would mean that countries
outside of the eleven above have a
Wizarding population density of 0.001
four percent I'm not sure if this is
gratuitous or not the total world
population excluding the eight countries
that we know about is seven point eight
billion and if we subtract 1.1 billion
accounting for the eight countries were
left with 6.7 million the median
population of the eight countries that
we know about is a hundred and sixteen
million which multiplied by three to
account for the three mystery countries
is 348 million 6.7 billion minus 348
million equals six billion three hundred
and fifty-two Lily
next we're going to apply the population
density of zero point two zero zero one
four percent and apply it to the
remainder of the world population this
gives us a figure of eighty eight
thousand nine hundred and twenty-eight
magical folk that inhabit the rest of
the planet add this eighty eight
thousand nine hundred and twenty eight
to the thirty thousand one hundred and
forty seven that come from countries
with wizarding schools and boom we have
our total Wizarding population of one
hundred and nineteen thousand and
seventy five this would mean that
magical folk account for 0.001 five to
six percent of the population or one in
sixty five thousand five
hundred think about the population of
the city or town that you live in how
many witches and wizards are there a
figure of one hundred and nineteen
thousand 75 total and 1904 in the UK
makes quite a lot of sense especially if
we consider the fact that Wizarding
operations are conducted in an entirely
secret other world that runs parallel to
the regular world if the population was
similar in size the two would
undoubtedly collide more often a larger
population would also mean many more
violations of the statute of secrecy
which for the most part seems to be well
regulated by the ministry while I'm
mostly happy with this figure there are
many many variables involved when
calculating something like this so I'm
sure I've missed something what do you
guys think of the figure that I came to
if you guys have calculations of your
own then I'd love to hear them please
share them down in the comment section
below anyway that's it for this video
until next time you're a wizard Harry
[Music]